how do you feel
about and you were on this thing for a
good year how do you feel about keeping
up kardashians coming to an end
20 seasons and 14 years the show will be
done
after the final season airing in early
2021
what are your thoughts about that i got
a tear got a tear coming out you were in
it for a year for a good year
2011 yeah i was in the wedding the
wedding season
literally the wedding season um
something tells me
despite this show going away these women
are not going away anytime soon they're
gonna still be out there
um doing their thing but um
time to move uh on to a new group of
thoughts
on e you know i don't think e can get
rid of the brand i mean they've got to
stay on
on some level some i mean chris jenner
is not giving that up so somehow
they're staying you know it's funny
you're the thing in 2011. adam at the
wedding
right let's not sugarcoat it in 2009 i
helped a friend who was uh opening up
sushi samba
in las vegas so he wanted me to help him
get some celebrities most overpriced
sushi restaurants on the
freaking people have it in south beach
as well lincoln
you know short notice 17 i was trying to
help him get some celebrities just to
show up just to walk the red carpet this
is 2008.
it's either 2008 or 2009 so maybe the
kardashian show was a few months old
everybody knew who kim was right
but so on short notice i was able to
help him get baron davis
not bad he did yeah that was a big big
baller back then
um courtney kardashian nice and
nikki hilton okay but just to put it
into perspective of this
kardashian jenner empire this is 2009.
you know what their appearance fee was
back then
to walk the red carpet only they weren't
doing interviews they weren't they
probably didn't even hang
25 g for courtney kardashian
a few months into the show 25. i know
but back
i thought for back then before she was
here right now you know you ain't going
to pay 25. oh no
that's my point they paid me 25 grand to
walk the red carpet back come on
you got to get i'm talking about when
nobody knew who they were so think about
11 12 years later how much they're
making i mean i mean if scott disick
you know spins at a vegas club it's a
half million
i tell you one thing about these guys
the kardashians if
if they ever wrote a book on marketing
it will be a number one bestseller
week after week after week because
there's brilliance to the kardashian
last name you know to be able to stay
relevant for
20 seasons 14 years where people have
interest watching you from all walks of
life from executives
to the everyday people and each of you
have a hundred million followers on
instagram building an
empire together it's a lot of respect to
them so here's the question for you
the question becomes who's the next
family that people care about to replace
the kardashians the trumps yeah
i mean we already got that but who's
going to kee who's going to be the next
story here's the
do they go recruit a family like that
there's no way you can be as
interesting as the kardashians when you
consider bruce jenner and the gender
you know change for him when you
consider that robert kardashian was
involved in the oj
case i mean the sex tape for kim married
to kanye running for president
who knows what she's doing next wants to
take on martha stewart i don't think
there's any
country or any family that you can
approach that could even remotely come
close to this i think they have to
somehow stay attached to the kardashian
jenner brand now kylie's too big
kendall's too big so i'm not sure what
you do maybe you go after courtney's
kids or something
i'm not sure but there's no family that
can like even close
closely come to this and the thing to
watch is who's ryan seacrest gonna go
after if ryan seacrest ordains somebody
it's gonna happen but if not if he's not
involved
it won't you know the the the big story
the
the the most uh
non-story that that you hear from the
like the women are killing it obviously
yeah
kim courtney chloe chris kendall kylie
all the
other girls let's take just a quick look
at what's happened to all the men
in that situation the father dead
right at age like 45 how'd that happen
that was cancer though right
okay i'm just saying he's dead he didn't
need it
the the second father well now he's the
mother bruce jenner
okay robert kardashian the son
no one's seen this guy in years years
he he married a stripper had a kid with
her
nowhere to be found right lamar odom
full-on crackhead
rehab nowhere to be found right out of
the league ruined his entire career
scott disick good looking dude i've
partied with this guy
many times rehab now he's literally
dating a 19 year old girl with three
kids
he has three kids he was seen being with
courtney by the way just last night
raising the kids i mean okay so who else
you got there
um so you say obviously kanye who is
certified nuts in a good way because i
think he was you know music
yes but now he can't blame cards it's
been amplified
um so what other guys are there you're
saying k for cursed
right for the men my boy chris with a k
he got out he got out you know made 60
million in the nba he
you know he got out uh sort of unscathed
not rehab not dead not obese
when they got a divorce did he have to
pay half his wealth to her or
she had to pay him more wealth than him
they were married he didn't pay him or
not
100 days right well she got he got her a
big ring yeah believe me if you know
anything about that guy he ain't
dropping two million dollars on a
freaking ring it was sponsored by
sotheby's or tiffany's or
some some fancy so what's your
suggestion i'm just saying listeners for
everybody that's listen i think what
adam is saying
if you get a chance to date one of them
think twice about it is that kind of
what they're saying
freaking way so so kim calls you
tomorrow it didn't work
out with kanye she says adam i had a
thing for you years ago i wouldn't mind
you and i go
we did kick it but but if she calls you
and she says adam let's go out to dinner
tabloid purposes sign me up for real
life why are you turning red though why
is your face still i'm looking at him
because i'm texting her
he's got a bachelor party story for us
i've never seen him turn red adam's
turning
red on the podcast i've never seen a boy
in the house
so you do have a thing for camp so if
kim was cool i have nothing bad to say
about it to be honest
if kim honestly if kim was single okay
and she ha
yep if kim was single yeah and she
sincerely liked you you mean to tell me
you wouldn't go on a serious
you wouldn't have you wouldn't consider
serious relationship with him
wait you probably would not no i mean
that's not
i mean to be involved in that nonsense
i'm good is the show still on the air
because if the show's
no one's listening just so you know no
one's listening no one's watching but
i'm asking you
if kim had interest and so boy adam
sasnik
okay a guy who's good in business fun
hip cool trendy takes care of his nails
very cool
would you sincerely consider a
relationship sure why not oh you would
sure
okay all right that's good to know so
all the stuff you just said for others
not to do
you listen do as i say not as i do
ladies and gentlemen
oh we just learned a lot about it you
weren't gonna drop that thing i was
saying no no no you kept asking the
question sure but but i think the answer
is i think
the bigger question is which of those
girls would i actually date
if given the opportunity who would be
for sure kendall
really yeah sure why she's
uh number one gorgeous supermodel um
she's real meaning kylie's i mean when i
met kylie she was 15 years old yeah
i knew from the get-go i'm like this
girl is going to be a whole nonsensical
now she's 22 years old she looks like
she's going to look like she's 40 in no
time
lip implants fake tits just face lifts
billion dollars
yeah worth a bill i mean kendall's not
doing so bad either but
kendall's just naturally gorgeous
naturally yeah and she like she
of all of them yeah she stays under the
radar as much as she possible i mean she
i think she
maybe uh tolerates privacy a little bit
more than the others
how many guys watching this can see adam
and kim together by the way
if you can see comment below let us know